you
[Music]
I'm going to talk about the reasons why
we're here to some extent and then what
I'm doing about it so the reason why
we're here is in some sense the
extrapolation of the talk that we just
heard that progress is occurring is
occurring at a rapidly increasing rate
and absent some other disaster that we
could bring upon ourselves I think we
have to make the prudent assumption that
AI systems will be able to make
decisions in a broad sense better than
we can and what that really means is
that they're using more information than
we can individually take into account in
making a decision and they will be able
to look further ahead into the future
and so just as alphago could beat any of
us at playing go
you take the go board and you expand it
out to the world then we are going to be
dealing with superior decision making
capabilities from machines and this is
potentially an incredibly good thing
because everything we have everything
that's worthwhile about our civilization
comes from our intelligence and so if we
have access to significantly greater
sources of intelligence that we can use
then this will inevitably be a step
change in our civilization and of course
with any such powerful technology we
expect there to be some downsides the
possibility of using this and in
military fear has been raised and is
already occurring
but I'm not going to talk about that
there are sessions later on Eric talked
about the question of employment this is
another big theme of the conference I'd
like to talk about this one the the
possible end of the human race that's a
very lurid way to describe it and
fortunately the press are not here at
least if they are here they have to keep
quiet so why why are people talking
about this right what's wrong with
taking a technology that has all kinds
of beneficial uses and making it better
what what's the
problem and you can go back to a speech
given a little while ago if a machine
can think it might think more
intelligently and than we do and then
where should we be even if we could keep
the machines in a subservient position
for instance by turning off the power
I've highlighted turning off the power
because we'll get to that answer later
on a strategic moments we should as a
species be greatly humbled and this new
danger is certainly something that that
should give us anxiety so this was
actually a speech of Alan Turing in 1951
given on BBC Radio 3 as we now call it
so it's a very inchoate fear right
there's no real specification of why
this could be a problem just this sort
of general unease that making something
more intelligent than you could humble
your species and the gorillas here they
are having a meeting to discuss this is
their version of our meeting and they're
having this discussion and they say look
yeah you're right you know our ancestors
made these humans a few million years
ago and you know we have these inchoate
fears then and they turned out to be
true our species is humbled right but we
can actually be more specific than that
so here's another quote if we use to
achieve our purpose is a mechanical
agency with whose operation we cannot
interfere effectively we better be quite
sure that the purpose put into the
machine is the purpose which we really
desire there's a more specific reason
why there's a problem that you will put
some objective and the machine will
carry it out and it turns out not to be
the right one this is from a paper by
Norbert Wiener in 1960 written actually
in response to to the work by Arthur
Samuel showing that his checkered
playing program could learn to play
checkers much better than he could but
this could equally have been King Midas
talking you know 2,500 years ago
realizing that when you get exactly what
you say you want it's often not what you
really want and it's sometimes too late
so this is sometimes called the value
misalignment problem that AI systems
will be
be good at achieving an objective which
turns out not to be what we really want
and so if you said okay great well let's
look at everything we know about how to
how to design the objectives to avoid
this problem
unfortunately you find that there really
isn't very much to go on but all of
these fields that that are based on this
idea of optimizing objectives which is
not just AI but you can all make some
statistics and operations research and
control theory they all have this same
problem they assume that the objective
is just something that someone else
brings along to the game and then the
game is that we optimize the objective
and you know economists certainly notice
that things like profit and GDP which
are the sort of the official objectives
turn out not to be always the things
that we really want to be optimizing but
they haven't really figured out what to
do instead
and then Steve Omohundro and others
pointed out that there's a yet another
problem which is that whatever objective
you give to a machine it will need to
stay alive in order to achieve it our
and so this if there's a little takeaway
from the talkest you can't search the
coffee if you're dead right so if you
ask the machine to fetch the coffee
staying alive is a sub-goal affecting
the coffee and if you if you interfere
with the machine and its attempt to get
the coffee it will prevent you from
interfering it if you try to turn it off
it will take countermeasures to being
turned off because its objective is to
get the coffee so if you combine that
with value misalignment now you have a
system that has an objectives that you
don't like because you specified it
wrong and now it's defending itself
against any attempts to switch it off or
to change what it's doing then you get
the problem that you know science
fiction has talked about it's not a
spontaneous evil consciousness where the
machine wakes up and hates humans it's
just this combination of unfortunate
circumstances that arise from having a
very very powerful technology okay so
lots of people have said well you know
this is all rubbish
all right everything I've said is
complete nonsense and one of the first
responses in fact there are many
responses I've written the paper where I
list about 15 of these of these
responses and I think they're all kind
of defensive knee-jerk reactions that
haven't been thought through so you find
for example people in the AI community
saying having said for 60 years of
course we will get to human-level AI
despite what all those skeptics from the
philosophy community and everything all
those other people don't know what
they're talking about of course it will
get the human level AI and as soon as
you point out that that's the problem is
well of course we'll never get to
human-level AI but I just want to point
out that you know in history there have
been these occasions where other
powerful technologies have been stated
to be impossible so here's Ernest
Rutherford on September 11 1933 he gave
a speech in Leicester addressing the
British Association for the Advancement
of science and he said that essentially
there's no chance that we'll ever be
able to extract energy from atoms they
knew the energy was in there they could
calculate how much but they said there's
no possibility we'll ever be able to get
it out and even Einstein was extremely
doubtful that we would ever be able to
get anything out of out of the atoms and
then the next morning lady lard read
about this speech in the time and went
for a walk and invented the neutron
induced nuclear chain reaction so so
there's there's there's only been like a
few of these giant tech technological
step changes in our history and and this
one took 16 hours so so to say that you
know maybe this is the fifth or sixth
one that we're talking about to say that
it's never going to happen and to be
completely confident that we therefore
need to take no precautionary measures
whatsoever seems a little rash
okay so there's lots of other arguments
I'm not going to go through them all
I'll just just page through them I did
want to mention the last one the last
one which is it's very pernicious which
is um so it doesn't show up very well
but don't mention the risks it might be
bad for funding
so I've seen this not quite frequently
in recent years and if you just look at
what half of a nuclear power I go back
to the 50s and 60s where they were
trying to gain acceptance for nuclear
power there was every attempt to play
down all possible risks say it's
completely safe it'll be you know too
cheap to meter the electricity will be
free there's no pollution there's no
possibility of there ever being an
accident and what that leads to is a
lack of attention to the risks which
then leaves the Chernobyl which then
destroys the entire nuclear industry so
history shows it's exactly the other way
around that if you suppress the risks
you will destroy technological progress
because then the risk will come to pass
okay
so I hope that you are now convinced
that there is a problem and so what are
we going to do about it because that's
the other thing right okay yes I agree
with you this is the George Bush
response okay yeah global warming is
going to happen but it's too late to do
anything about it now what are we going
to do about this so the work I'm going
to talk about now is happening under a
new center that max mentioned the center
for human compatible AI at Berkeley
which is funded by the open philanthropy
project and what we're basically trying
to do is to change the way that we think
about AI away from this notion of pure
intelligence that the pure optimizer
that can take any objective you like and
just optimize it and naturally look at a
more comprehensive kind of system which
is guaranteed to be beneficial to the
user in some sense there's a lot of
other work that I don't have time to
talk about many of these new centers and
also those professional societies have
started to become very interested in
these problems as well as the funding
agencies and industry so the work at the
center is based on three simple ideas
the first of all that the robots only
objective should be to maximize the
realization of human values and the
second point is the robot doesn't know
what those are but nonetheless its
objective is to do this
so these two points together it turns
out actually makes a significant
difference to how we design AI systems
and the properties that they have so
obviously if the robot has no idea about
what human values are and never
discovers what they are that's not going
to be very useful to us so it has to
have some means of learning and the best
source of information about human values
is human behavior that the standard idea
a longstanding idea in economics for
example that our actions reveal our
preferences and this allows for a
process that results in value alignment
and joshua mentioned on one of his slide
a fairly old idea 20 years old now
inverse reinforcement learning which is
the opposite of reinforcement learning
or the dual so in reinforcement learning
we provide a reward signal on the system
has to figure out how to behave in
inverse reinforcement learning we
provide the behavior in other words the
Machine sees our behavior and has to
figure out what is the reward function
that's being optimized by this behavior
so in economics this is known as
structural estimation of MVPs which is a
somewhat of a mouthful in control theory
inverse optimal control so it's a fairly
an idea that sprung up independently in
several different disciplines and
there's now a fairly well advanced
theory lots and lots of papers
demonstrations that this technique can
be successful in learning lots of
different kinds of behaviors so it isn't
quite what we want for one thing we
don't want the robot to to learn our
value function and adopt it so if it
sees me drinking coffee I don't want the
robot to want coffee because that's not
the that's not the right thing that we
want to happen we want the robot to know
that I want coffee and to have the
objective of getting me coffee whatever
it might be so a slight generalization
is cooperative inverse reinforcement
learning which is which is a two-player
game in generally there will be many
humans and many robots but to start with
one human and one robot and the human in
some sense knows their own value
function but only in that they can act
approximately
according to it doesn't mean they can
explicate it and write it down and give
it to the robot but they have there's
some connection between their value
function and their actions the robot
doesn't know what it is but its
objective is as I said before to
maximize the human value function so
when you write down simple instances of
this game then you can solve it
mathematically you can look at how the
system's behave as they play this game
and as you would hope some nice things
happen so the robot now has an incentive
to ask questions first so it doesn't
just do whatever it thinks is best it
can ask you know is this a good idea I
can ask you know which of these two
things might I do and the human now has
an incentive to teach the robot because
by teaching the robot the robot will
become more useful and so the behavior
of both parties is considerably changed
by being in this game so I want to look
at one particular instance of this game
which we call the off switch problem and
the opposite problem arises because
based on the argument of instrumental
goals the idea that you can't fetch the
coffee if you're dead any attempt to
switch off a robot you know is going to
result in countermeasures by the robot
and this seems like a problem that's
almost unavoidable right we said you
know for pretty much any objectives very
hard to think of an objective that you
can carry out better after you're dead
than before it and so this is a
fundamental problem and Turing's
assumption that we could just switch off
the super intelligent machine is kind of
like saying well you know if you're
worried about losing the game of chess
you can just beat the blue just play
better move right it's not as easy as
that
but there is an answer which is that the
robot should not be given a specific
objective we want the robot to be humble
in the sense the robot should know that
it does not know the true objective and
then it's single-minded pursuit of the
objective and it's self defense against
any interference will actually evaporate
so if if the human is
going to switch off the robot why would
it do that the reason is that the robot
is doing something that the human
doesn't like the robot of course thinks
that what it's doing is what the human
likes but it acknowledges that there's a
possibility that it's wrong and so if
the human is going to switch the robot
off the robot learns in some sense for
being switched off that what it was
doing was undesirable and therefore
being switched off is better for its
objective which is to optimize the human
value function and so now the robot
actually has a positive incentive to
allow itself to be switched off it does
not have a positive incentive to switch
itself off so I won't commit suicide but
it will allow the human to switch it off
and this is a very straightforward
analog of the theorem of the non
negative expected value of information
but in some sense the humans action is
switching off is a form of information
and the robot welcomes that if it
happens so this leads actually to sort
of a rethinking a little bit of of how
we go about doing AI that that
uncertainty and objectives turns out to
be quite important and it's been ignored
even though uncertainty and all kinds of
other parts of AI has been studied
intensively since the early 80s
uncertainty in the objectives has been
almost completely ignored one reason is
that in the standard formulation of
decision problems Markov decision
processes and so on uncertainty in
objectives is actually provably
irrelevant because you're trying to
optimize an expected reward and if
there's uncertainty over the reward then
you can simply integrate over the
uncertainty and your behavior will be
exactly the same as if you knew the
expected value of that reward but that
theorem only holds if the environment
contains no information about the reward
so as soon as the environment can
provide more information then that
theorem is invalid and clearly if what
you care about is the human value
function and a human is in your
environment and the human can act then
those actions provide information about
the reward function similarly the
human one particular kind of action is
the provision of reward signal so
reinforcement learning can occur by
humans providing a reward signal now
let's go and look at a little bit of a
little bit of history a reward signal
and so here here are some well-known
experiments on what Kauai aheading so a
rat will actually sort of circumvent its
normal behavior and will actually starve
itself to death if you give the ability
to the rat to basically provide reward
signals directly either by chemicals or
by electrical stimulation even though
it's starving to death it will do that
instead of eating so a human actually
will behave the same way these are some
very interesting experiments in 1950s so
in any real situation unlike the
mathematical model of reinforcement
learning where the reward signal is
provided exhaustion ously sort of as it
were by God in the real world
someone has to provide the reward signal
you if you're providing the reward
signal are part of the environment and
the reinforcement learning agent will
hijack the reward generating mechanism
and if that's you then it will hijack
you and force you to provide a maximal
reward but this actually just results
from a mistake the masam and it's
interesting that by looking at it from
this different perspective from the
perspective of cooperative inverse
reinforcement learning we realize that
the standard formulation of
reinforcement learning is just wrong the
signal given to the agent is not a
reward it is information about the
reward and you just change the
mathematical formulation to have that
definition instead and then the
hijacking becomes completely pointless
because if you hijack something that's
providing information all you do is get
less information you don't get more
reward you get less information and so
we can avoid wire heading by
reformulating RL to have a information
base rather than reward based signals so
that leads to a general approach that
we're taking within the sensor that when
we define a formal problem what we are
going to do is build agents that are
designed
mathematically to solve that problem and
then we want to understand do those
agents behave in ways that make us happy
so we are not trying to solve the
problem that someone else is building a
an AGI from generally intelligent agent
and then we are going to somehow defend
against it like that's not the right way
to think the right way you think is to
find a formal problem build agents that
fold it and they can solve it
arbitrarily well they can be arbitrarily
brilliant but they are fall with all
that problem F and then show that the
human will benefit from having such a
such a machine okay so this is a
difficult problem there is a lot of
information about human behavior in our
history everything we write down is a
record of human behavior so there's a
massive amount of data that we're not
really using that can be used to learn
about what the human value system is so
that's good there's also a strong
economic incentive so Google found out
for example if you if you write down
your value function and say that the
costs of misclassification of one type
of object as another are all equal for
every type of object and everything you
could miss classify it as that value
function is wrong and then you lose a
lot of a lot of reputation as a result
you can also imagine that you know a few
years down the road mistakes in
understanding human value functions will
cause a very significant backlash
against in the industry that produced
that mistake so this is very strong
incentive to get this value system right
even before we reach the stage of having
superhuman AI there are some reasons for
pessimism which I always translate into
reasons for working hard and that is
that humans are very complicated they
are not optimizes they are very
complicated systems that there are lots
of them and they're all different and
some of them you don't really want to
learn from and so on these are problems
where we need social science to help us
and it makes things much more difficult
but also much more interesting so I
recommend that we work on practical
projects that we don't simply speculate
about what a GIS might be like and and
and write sort of interesting but
ultimately
our implementable ideas about how we
might control them that we actually look
at practical projects on real systems so
I think with an authentic we'll probably
be looking at intelligent personal
assistant other people might look at
things like smart homes where clearly
there are things that could go wrong and
there are there are incentives to get
this right early on it would be nice to
have simulation environments where in
fact real simulated disasters could
happen so we can get more of a sense
this will be a sort of a generator of
ideas about what can go wrong and then
how we might try to address it so I
think yan is getting impatient so we're
really aiming at a change in the way
that AI defines itself so we shouldn't
be talking about safe AI or beneficial
AI any more than a civil engineer talks
about building bridges that don't fall
down it's just part of the definition of
a bridge that it doesn't fall down it
should be part of the definition of AI
that is beneficial that it's safe and
this is not a separate AI safety
community that's nagging the real AI
community this should be what they I
community does intrinsically and in a
state of a business we want social
scientists to be involved we would like
to understand a lot more about the
actual human value system because it
really matters we're not building AI to
benefit bacteria we're doing AI to
benefit us and hopefully it'll make us
better people that will learn a lot more
about what our value systems are or
could be and by making that a bit more
explicit it'll be easier for us to be
good so to speak so Weiner
going back to his paper from 1960 and
going back to the slightly more gloomy
color of the earlier part of the talk he
pointed out that this is incredibly
difficult to do but we don't have a
choice right we can't just say oh this
is too far off in the future too
difficult to make any predictions we
have to you know just continue as if
nothing was going to happen
the problem is bigger and more difficult
but that still doesn't mean we should
ignore it thank you
Thanks I was very sure you liked your
formulation of the problem as a
two-player cooperative game and
addressing the question about switching
off AI possibly I don't think I
understood it entirely though how is
that particular choice by humans
different than other choices if you say
I want to move the bishop here I want to
push the throttle forward I want to
drive off the bridge I want to take the
red pill how does the AI know oh this is
one where I let the human overrule and
this other one maybe I shouldn't let the
human decide is there a distinction
between that choice and other choices if
you're uncertain yeah there is I mean I
think and it also depends on your on
your model of the human so if you if you
have a self-driving car it has an off
switch but if a self-driving car is
transporting a you know a two-year-old
you may want you may want to disable the
off switch it's like that's the right
thing to do so you can calculate the
expected value to the human of of having
an off switch that type six right now
sometimes yeah sometimes the officer
should be disabled so so the whole the
whole evaluation is to look at the value
of the human plus the robot system is
that is the human better off with the
robot or better off not with the robot
and we only want robots where the human
is provably better off and sometimes
that means the robot shouldn't allow
itself to be switched off so we know a
robot anesthesiologist that's keeping
you alive while you're unconscious right
is not relying on any of the decisions
that you're making right and you want to
you want to trust it completely while
you're unconscious so it depends on the
circumstance but the off switch problem
right that curing originally proposed is
a intelligent human who thinks they can
switch off the machine but turns out
they can't one more question
Andy Andy McAfee MIT this is an on/off
switch question you brought up the great
example of nuclear power as a case where
maybe under discussion of risks got the
field into trouble the next example in
your slide was GMOs which seems like a
really interesting case in
click the opposite direction where the
scientific consensus about safety there
is at least as strong as the consensus
for chemical human human caused global
warming and yet a lot of that that
technology is not diffusing and a lot of
people are made much worse off because
of over emphasis on the risk could you
comment on why you added GMOs to that
slide and what you conclude from it yeah
I I I thought I thought through this
this case and partly so in fact the the
Prime Minister's office in the UK asked
me to go talk to them because they were
worried that AI might be subject to the
same negative outcome that happened with
with GMOs in Europe I don't think
there's any real danger of that I mean
the the level of investment in the the
acceleration of investment in AI is is
enormous and it's also it's a different
type of thing it's very hard to ban AI
which is really people writing formulas
on whiteboards it's not it's not a
particular organism or or a particular
chemical that you could put on the field
or not put on the field but I think what
happened with GMOs is that the industry
went into a defensive mode where they
would deny any and all possible risks
and so it ended up not being of it not
being seen as an honest discussion that
was going on it was very much the
industry versus the people who had
doubts or questions were trashed people
were mr. industry with funding other
people outside a supposedly outside to
write negative articles smearing the
people who are doing the research but
might raise questions about GMOs so it
was a they adopted the classic technique
that for example the tobacco industry
adopted and I think that resulted in
skepticism
but they're right but it was the
techniques that they adopted in the
discussion right to deny risk to say
that all these questions are answered
trust us we know well in fact there were
things they didn't know and it's turned
out that the some of the negative sex
people predicted haven't come to pass
but it wasn't that they had already done
all the science they just simply denied
that anything could possibly go wrong
so I think that it was more of a
political failure and the political
failure was not that they were they were
right and everyone else was stupid it's
that they adopted this approach that
everyone else was stupid and that they
were right and that didn't work
[Music]